[Music]
these are satellite images from the
deserts of western China look closely
and you'll see these huge complexes
being built from the sky they sort of
look like factories or even schools but
look even closer this line is one
facility's perimeter wall and these
shadows they're cast by watchtowers
along the wall this compound isn't a
school or a factory it's an internment
camp inside these camps the Chinese
government is detaining as many as 1
million Leaguers China's mostly Muslim
minority China doesn't want the world to
know any of this but the story of these
camps is also the story of how we know
about them and China's efforts to cover
them up as soon as we began to document
the re-education centers there was
Chinese government officials deleting
what we were finding we Gers mainly live
here in the Shin Jung province of
northwestern China that puts them closer
to the capitals of Kyrgyzstan and
Uzbekistan than to Beijing and we Gers
are also closer culturally to those
Turkic groups than they are to the Han
Chinese China's ethnic majority the
weaker speak a Turkic language their
culture is different they have
particular styles of music a whole rich
history that is unique to them this is
Segal Samuel a reporter at Fox I've been
reporting on the Weger crisis in China
for about a year now
China has been concerned for decades
about the possibility of weaker
separatism weekers have actually had
their own independent nation two
separate times in the last century in
1933 they established the Islamic
Republic of East Turkestan here in
Kashgar but it crumbled less than a year
later when it was taken over by Chinese
forces then in 1944 the Soviet Union
backed the creation of the East
Turkestan Republic based here but when
China became communist in 1949 the
Soviet Union turned on East Turkestan
and helped China take it over again part
of why the shinjang region is so
important to China is that it's rich
with energy resources and as China's
economy grew so did its need for energy
today Shin Jung accounts for nearly 40
percent of China's coal reserves and
over 20% of the country's oil and gas it
also accounts for 20% of China's
potential for wind energy China needs
resources it needs energy
it means the the geographical location
the area on which Shin Jang sits that's
where we giris are that's where they're
living and so China really wants to have
a solid sense of control over that area
as far back as the 1950s China saw an
opportunity to dilute the influence of
the potentially rebellious Wiegert and
started encouraging the migration of Han
Chinese into Shin Jung and it worked in
1945 we Gers made up over 80% of the
population compared to just 6% han
chinese by 2008 Shin Jang was 46% Weger
compared to 39% Han Chinese but over the
years as Shin Jung developed
economically we Gers were left behind
working mostly low-wage jobs in
agriculture while the Han held higher
paying jobs
finally in 2009 a weaker protest against
discrimination at the hands of the Han
and the Chinese government erupted in
violence bloody riots broke out pitting
ethnic we're Muslims against the
dominant Han Chinese one of the worst
riots took place in the provincial
capital of your room Qi about 200 people
were killed and hundreds injured during
the unrest that was sort of an
inflection point after that the Chinese
really started to crack down harder on
the weavers and by 2013 Shin Jang had
become even more important to China the
country launched the belt and Road
initiative a trillion dollar investment
in things like fiber optic cables train
lines and gas pipelines meant to boost
the country's economic and political
influence around the world by making it
easier to trade with China if you plot
these projects on a map you'll see a lot
of them passed through Shin Jung making
the province arguably the most important
corridor for the whole project China
would need to ensure that Shin Jang
remained securely in its hands The
Weavers came to be perceived and and
painted more as a threat as a separatist
threat as an extremist threat in 2016
and 2017 the country enacted a series of
D extrema fication policies aimed at
Muslims like banning long beards and
shin jon was effectively turned into a
high-tech police state so this kind of
thing is happening all over the country
but in Xinjiang it's been just increased
by orders of magnitude we're talking
about we Gers having to hand over their
phones at checkpoints we're even talking
about QR codes being installed on the
outside of their homes
but the most brutal part of this
crackdown was hidden to the world at
first in this image you see opening of
this facility the signage says the
extrema fication re-education center
around 2017 China started building these
internment camps these large-scale
places to detain we Gers china says that
these camps are necessary because the
weavers are a terrorist threat a
separatist threat people who are
infected with extremist thinking but it
wasn't until Biggers who had been
detained told their stories that the
picture from inside the camps came into
clearer focus they're forced to memorize
and recite Communist Party propaganda
every day they're often forced to
criticize their own Islamic beliefs and
to criticize the beliefs of their fellow
detainees we had to sing songs hailing
the Communist Party
we had to repeat in Chinese long live Xi
Jinping there have been reports of death
of torture three guards surrounded me
and abused me so Sentosa each time I was
electrocuted my whole body would shake
so there's this atmosphere of just
trying to uproot what you believe in
[Music]
at first China denied the existence of
these camps
c'mon Angela yeh Hsiang shota see
empezar quitting de jong joseon CEO
Serena competent a new Kentucky da de
acá para dong zhuo show the Solway de
seems always were an event here but
activists and academics fought back a
lot of people around the world are
scouring the internet for evidence of
China's internment camps for Weaver's in
terms of the strategies and tools that
I've used and others have used to
uncover evidence of these camps it's
quite simply a computer and knowledge of
Chinese and thinking about what words
especially government websites would use
people have unearthed government
documents and then we had growing visual
evidence we're looking at satellite
images we could actually trace the
creation expansion of the re-education
camp it was a matter of I think luck or
chance I uncovered this image and until
then we didn't have we didn't have that
piece of visual evidence that said this
is what it is and this is what the
Chinese government is calling it Tim
isn't alone there's a whole network of
websites around the world using basic
internet tools to document what China
doesn't want the world to see and
they've gotten China to change their
story at least a little China was
denying that these reeducation centers
exist until journalists and academics
and others started to really amass a
body of evidence that was so convincing
that China couldn't just deny it anymore
China took a different approach and
started admitting that these facilities
exist but carefully painted them as
training schools for potential criminals
or terrorists traditional drum machine
nachos Lisa took a cheese fellatio
[Music]
in the meantime the camps are still
there and growing this camp one of
China's largest was as big as the nearby
city of Devon Chung in 2017 but by 2018
the camp had expanded to twice the size
from China's perspective they think it's
worth it and they want to make sure Shin
Jang is an area of the country that they
have total control over and if that
comes with a high human cost and even a
reputational blow on the international
stage China so far seems willing to do
that anyway
[Music]
you